vamos a continuar llenando nuestra tabla
de transformadas de la plaza y una buena
manera de hacerlo es escribir nuestra
definición de la transformada de la
plaza la transformada de la plaza de una
función de t va a ser igual a la
integral impropia de 0 infinito
de al menos siete por efe dt dt
esta es nuestra definición y la primera
transformada de laplace que hicimos es
la transformada de la plaza de uno en la
que por ejemplo puede serte elevada a la
cero y esto es igual a la integral y
propia de cero a infinito de al menos 7
y ft es igual a 1 así que queda dt y
esto va a ser igual
- 1 / s por la sct
evaluado de 0 a infinito
cuando tomamos el límite de este término
cuando t se aproxima al infinito
este ala menos este se convierte en un
número muy grande un número negativo muy
grande cuando s es mayor que 0
todo este término va a tender a cero va
a ser cero menos este término evaluado
cuando t es igual a cero elevado a la
cero va a ser igual a 1 por lo que nos
va a quedar un -1 entre s que es lo
mismo que más 1 entre s así que la
transformada de laplace de uno va a ser
igual a uno entre s así que la
transformada de la función uno va a ser
1 entre s vamos a tratar de calcular
algo más elevado vamos a ver la
transformada de la plaza de t
nuestra ft es igual a t y esto va a ser
igual a la integral impropia de 0 a
infinito
de al menos 7 portes de té bueno
puedo decirles en este momento que no he
memorizado la anti derivada de esto pero
nos puede ayudar la integración por
partes a resolver esto ya que la
integración por partes nos permite
descomponer esto en elementos más
sencillos y yo siempre me olvido de cómo
es la integración por partes así que la
voy a inferir
por de la derivada de esto va a ser
igual a la derivada de la primera por la
segunda
más la primera por la derivada de la
segunda es la regla del producto ahora
sí hacemos la integral en ambos lados
vamos a obtener por b es igual a la
integral de prima por ve más la integral
de por bp lima ya que vamos a aplicar
esto a una integral
vamos a dejarlo en términos de lo que
queremos resolver la integral de x de
prima es igual vamos a restar esto de
este otro lado de la ecuación
aquí lo único que estoy haciendo es
intercambiar estos lados y quitar esto
de este otro lado para que me quede un
por ve - integral de un prima por d
y aquí está aunque no me he aprendido
esta fórmula realmente no es difícil de
inferir siempre y cuando ustedes
recuerden la regla de producto de
integrales así que si vamos a hacer una
integración por partes
es bueno que definamos nuestra prima de
una manera que sea sencillo encontrar la
anti derivada y también es bueno en
definido de manera que sea fácil
encontrar su derivada así que vamos a
hacer que te sea nuestra función
y nuestra función be prima va a ser la
menos 7 y si este es el caso bueno ahora
vamos a encontrar cuál es el valor de t
b va a ser la anti derivada de b prima
que es menos 1 entre s por el ala menos
st
y ahora también tenemos que encontrar
nuestra prima
es la derivada de un así que esta prima
va a ser igual a 1 y ahora sí vamos a
aplicar esto la transformada de la plaza
de t
la transformada de la plaza de té
es igual
tarde
este pibe es lo que tenemos aquí
esto es x menos 1 / s por el ala menos
st
al menos 7
y esta es la integral indefinida
esto todavía lo tenemos que evaluar de 0
a infinito menos la integral menos la
integral
de 0 a infinito
de su prima y vemos que prima es 1 x b&b
es esta parte menos
ahora -1 entre ese de choclo pongan otro
color por al menos 7
- ese porte dt siempre agregamos aquí de
té
y esto vamos a ver si podemos
simplificar esto esto va a ser igual
- t / s por el ala menos st
esto evaluado de 0 a infinito
x 1 bueno esto podemos evitar escribirlo
pues un 1 nada más y nos queda menos por
menos es más más 1 entre s por la
integral de 0 a infinito d
a la - st por dt y esto les debe de ser
familiar
esta es la transformada de laplace de 1
así que le vamos a tener esto en mente
es la transformada de la plaza de uno
vamos a escribirlo aquí porque vamos a
encontrar un patrón que veremos en el
siguiente vídeo
así que bueno aquí lo escribimos
y ahora vamos a evaluar todo esto
vamos a evaluar esta expresión cuando te
tiende a infinito y le vamos a quitar la
expresión cuando te es igual a cero esto
va a ser igual y permítanme escribirlo
de esta manera va a ser el límite cuando
tiene infinito de menos a sobre s por el
ala menos s por a
esto es cuando yo evalúo esta expresión
cuando te tiende a infinito y a esto le
vamos a restar esta expresión cuando te
es igual a cero así que esto va a ser
más cero entre s por el ala menos s por
cero y por supuesto aquí vamos a tener
tenemos este término de aquí que este
término lo voy a escribir en amarillo no
mejoran azul
1 / s qué es esto multiplicado por la
transformada de la clase 1
qué es lo que obtenemos aquí
veamos cuál es el límite de esto
conforme a se aproxima al infinito
podrías decir que bueno pues esto va a
ser un número muy muy grande así que va
a ser un número negativo muy grande este
va a ser un exponente así que es la
menos infinito y van a atender a 0 mucho
más rápido de lo que este otro término
tiende al infinito
este término de aquí
y digamos que una función mucho más
fuerte que la otra incluso pueden
ustedes tomar una calculadora y
comprobarlo si no me creen así que todo
este término va a tender a cero y de la
misma manera si tenemos esto que
multiplica a un cero pues todo este
término va a ser igual a cero
y eso es conveniente porque todos estos
términos se van a eliminar así que la
transformada de la plaza de t
va a ser igual a 1 / s x la transformada
de la plaza de 1
y ya sabemos que es la transformada de
laplace de 1 está transformada de la
plaza 1 aquí lo pongo en verde es uno
entre s asumiendo que s es mayor que 0 y
de hecho tenemos que asumir que ese es
mayor que 0 aquí para poder resolver
esto ya que solamente cuando aquí
tenemos un menos infinito es que todo
esto tiende a cero muy bien entonces
tenemos que la transformada de la plaza
de t es igual a 1 entre s por 1 entre s
y esto es igual a 1 entre ese cuadrado
siempre y cuando ese sea mayor que 0 así
que esta es nuestra siguiente entrada en
nuestra tabla de transformadas de la
plaza y podemos usar esto en el
siguiente vídeo lo vamos a hacer para
encontrar la transformada de la plaza
dt a la n
esto lo vamos a hacer en el siguiente
vídeo